There’s a mod for Red Dead Redemption II…
that lets you play as any animal in the game’s
ecosystem.
And it is, quite literally, a transformative
experience.
With this mod I tore through a town as a deer,
and I raced through the grass as a mountain
lion, and I soared through the skies as an
eagle…
And through it all, I gained a new understanding
of a world I thought I was already deeply
familiar with.
I knew this virtual ecosystem was vibrant,
but by changing my perspective, I realized…
it’s alive.
Some worlds feel like they exist long before
you press play.
When a game pulls this off, the results can
be breathtaking — and sometimes even a little
uncanny.
So let’s discover what makes a digital ecosystem
truly seem to have a life of its own…
Even without mods that expand your perspective,
the world of Red Dead is obsessively detailed.
Snow realistically falls from branches as
you wander past, the eyes of owl’s glow
in the dark, depending on the ambient temperature,
there’s realistic growth and shrinkage of
your horse’s — okay we’re skipping that
— but it proves my point!
This game’s commitment to environmental
minutiae is absurd.
Which is probably why playing as an animal
genuinely feels like a kind of… existential
voyage.
I don’t want to over-exaggerate, but I mean
it when I say this game is so immersive, it’s
hard not to lose yourself within each new
perspective.
Every animal made me see the ecosystem a different
way, and reevaluate my position within it.
Inhabiting different roles in an ecosystem…
is even more essential to a game like Lost
Ember.
Developed by an indie studio, the entire experience
revolves around changing forms — choosing
the perfect time to transfer your consciousness
to a different link in the food chain.
You play as a Soul Wanderer, a reincarnated
spirit that can periodically take over the
bodies of nearby lifeforms to navigate a hostile
environment.
It’s a little tricky to get the hang of
at first, but the more you practice, the more
natural it becomes to constantly be changing
between different modes of existence.
No two species feel the same: being a wombat
is a leisurely existence, while being a hummingbird
is frantic — fitting for an animal with
a heart that beats over a thousand times per
minute.
And since every creature has their own terrain
they’re adept at navigating, you can never
settle into one form for too long.
Like in Red Dead, the multiple perspectives
give you a greater understanding of larger
ecosystems, to the point where it’s impossible
to imagine the game without this mechanic.
But here’s what’s weird.
The shape-changing feature isn’t actually
supposed to be in Red Dead at all, and yet
like Lost Ember, it feels fundamental.
For example, while playing this mod I realized
that every bird takes off slightly differently.
It even seems that heavy species like condors
can’t take off directly from the ground,
and need a realistically elevated position
to soar through the skies.
But pretty much the only time you see birds
in this game is from a great distance on horseback,
so why include these intricacies?
This mod doesn’t add any animations — all
these elements were here in the base game
… just waiting to be uncovered.
Each bird also has a distinctive flight pattern,
except for bats, which have their own, completely
unique flight system.
I didn’t even know there were bats in this
game — I’ve never seen one before!
…I’ve beaten it twice!
…What compels a studio to focus this much
on tiny details — details that the vast
majority of players are never going to uncover?
If any game can help us answer that question,
it has to be Dwarf Fortress, quite possibly
the most labyrinthine and complicated title
ever conceived.
The product of almost twenty years of work
by a pair of brothers, every time you press
start, the game generates a new world, calculating
rainfall and mineral distribution and temperature
and elevation and a hundred other things.
You can watch thousands of years of simulated
history flicker by, a timeline of events generated
in the top corner chronicling wars and treaties
and betrayals and losses… and that’s just
the abridged version.
The full history of my first game included
five-hundred, twenty-five thousand and eighty-six
events — all before I started playing.
Trying to actually beat Dwarf Fortress is
potentially even more complicated.
But I think that bewildering intricacy is
the point to an extent.
In the original text-based game, you manage
countless entities represented by letters,
which can be overwhelming…
but also mesmerizing.
I know I’ll never fully comprehend this
gargantuan bionetwork — but that just makes
it feel more like an actual world, the kind
of ecosystem you could spend a lifetime studying.
Of course, you could also spend a lifetime
studying the smallest ecosystem.
Ants Simulation is the pinnacle of specificity.
Created by youtuber Pezzza, it’s incredible
how thoroughly this project replicates the
movements of the real insects.
Every simulated worker leaves behind a chemical
path just like in nature to guide their nestmates
to sources of food.
Two different colonies of ants will fight
over the same resources, the conflict realistically
breaking off into numerous skirmishes.
Ant simulator doesn’t boast thousands of
years of lore like Dwarf Fortress, and yet
the interactions feel no less important, proving
that a micro-world can be just as impactful
as a macro one.
This is true in other digital ecosystems as
well: there’s a reason why players are so
excited to find ants in Skyrim, a title where
you regularly fight dragons.
Sometimes, it’s the smallest details that
make an ecosystem feel alive.
Take mud, for instance.
Okay, hear me out on this.
The mud in Red Dead is beautiful.
The way people and animals and carts all leave
tracks through it adds so much to the environments.
If you accidentally fall into the mud, it
gets all over your clothes — it seems so
physical.
Which is why I was surprised to learn it’s
flat.
And not just flat because it’s on a TV screen
— I mean flat compared to the rest of the
game’s 3D rendering.
People have gone into the files and discovered
this mud is just a 2D texture, with the deep
footprints all a clever optical illusion.
And that’s not a bad thing, you can’t
really render a virtual ecosystem on current
hardware without carefully allocating resources.
But it is a noteworthy paradox that many of
the worlds that feel the most alive must constantly
cull things out.
The beautiful, rippling grasses of games like
Tears of the Kingdom can only exist because
the world is lowering the quality of plants
that are further away.
In fact, for most modern games, any part of
the terrain that isn’t within the player’s
immediate cone of vision is constantly being
rendered out.
And again, I want to make it clear that none
of these techniques are bad — without them,
most digital ecosystems couldn’t exist at
all.
So why is it that I feel slightly uneasy when
I learn that a game like Insomniac’s Spider-Man
contains thousands — tens of thousands — of
false environments?
The vast majority of interiors you can see
through windows in this game are illusions,
completely flat images like Red Dead’s mud,
made to look full of depth through a clever
trick of programing.
It’s a conceit that makes total sense — New
York in this game is an urban ecosystem just
as detailed as any biological one; there’s
no way the developers could render every single
apartment.
I know that.
And yet there’s still something strange
to me about peering into a space and knowing
it’s not there.
This strangeness isn’t unique to game environments.
Movies have been using similar techniques
for decades, creating numerous fantastical
ecosystems through well-placed flat images.
The traditional film method for creating imagined
environments was the matte painting, which
was combined with live action footage in the
days before cgi.
The original Star Wars trilogy made use of
techniques like this a lot — with numerous
scenes merging sets with paintings in ways
that are almost impossible to notice.
It really is something of a lost worldbuilding
art.
It’s likely you’ve seen some landscapes
in movies you haven’t even realized were
paintings.
Even still, you might have felt something
was off.
A slight, nagging sense of unreality.
And of course, in some cases, it’s easier
to tell than others, with the very seams visible
if you look closely.
The seams in virtual ecosystems typically
aren’t as obvious.
But you can spot them too if you know what
to look for.
Any moment in a modern game that requires
you to stop and move through a tight space
is probably buying time to load in the next
area.
This strategy is honestly pretty clever, and
shows how carefully streamlined virtual words
have to be.
Maybe that’s why when a game includes useless
details — like ants or overly-specific flight
animations, it feels so revelatory.
Like you turned around too fast and instead
of catching the seams, you caught the game
being alive in a way that it shouldn’t.
This is a huge part of why the ecosystem of
a game like Rain World seems to have a life
of its own.
In that title, creature interactions are simulated
even when you aren’t onscreen, which means
you’ll constantly stumble upon unfolding
dramas that have nothing to do with your journey.
It feels like the world simply exists far
beyond the confines of the camera.
If there’s a film equivalent to this kind
of environment, it’s probably the expansive,
360-degree physical set — which are becoming
increasingly rare.
Though less practical than a static backdrop
or green screen, these types of sets have
total immersion quality I find extremely compelling.
These are worlds that people actually built
and walked through.
Like the Roman Forum from the film Cleopatra,
an absolutely monstrous construction that
bankrupted the studio.
Its proportions were more than double that
of the actual Roman Forum.
And since this film was a financial bomb,
it’s also something of a monument to the
hubristic end of old Hollywood, a historical
site in its own right — though not one that’s
survived to present day.
I also think of the Atoll set from Waterworld,
which was a quarter mile in circumference.
Production of this movie reportedly swallowed
up every piece of steel in Hawaii, requiring
more to be flown in from California.
This film was also a financial bomb.
You might question what such anecdotes have
to do with video game ecosystems, but I think
there’s a real commonality across these
obsessive attempts at crafting convincing
fictional environments.
Perhaps it’s a natural creative inclination
to chase the dream of an imagined world without
boundary.
It can also, clearly, be disastrous — and
even dangerous.
At what point does a fictional world stop
being fictional?
This is a question essential to the production
of “Dau.”
What began as a single movie turned into a
two-year long experiment where over a thousand
actors and extras lived in a closed-off replica
of Cold-War era Russia.
Whether on or off camera, people on set had
to remain fully in character, working actual
jobs for period-appropriate currency.
This Truman Show-like simulation was 12,000
square miles, the largest set ever built in
Europe.
And the institutional corruption the movie
grapples with reportedly spilled over into
life on the set, with allegations of mistreatment
surrounding the production.
And despite all these efforts to create authentic
setting — the movie isn’t even supposed
to be very good!
(Crowd Noises)
Did you know that there’s over a thousand
unique characters in Red Dead?
The vast majority exist in the background,
full-time extras in a digital set, their sole
purpose to make the environments you walk
through more lifelike.
Yet if you decide to follow one throughout
their day, you’ll find most of these digital
people have a full daily routine.
They wake up each morning and go to work.
Some toil away for long hours.
Others slack off when they can.
When night falls, people amble home at different
speeds.
Some have families to get back to.
Others seem… achingly lonely.
Early in this video, I said that worlds that
seem like they exist before you press play
can feel uncanny.
Red Dead’s world, with its almost unhinged
devotion to realism, can certainly fall into
that category.
Left unchecked, the pursuit of a living fictional
world can be a kind of madness.
You can see this quite plainly across the
multi decade career of game designer Peter
Molyneux.
A founding influence in the so-called ‘God-Games’
genre, his projects frequently give you command
of not just ecosystems, but entire worlds,
and are usually ambitious to the point of
collapsing under their own weight — the
Cleopatras and Waterworlds of gaming.
There’s a reason why not that many other
studios have even attempted to make games
like this — trying to make worlds at this
level of complexity can often lead to setbacks
and broken promises.
That said, a part of me sympathizes with how
Molyneux’s desire to create outpaces what
he can actually produce.
The wildly anticipated Fable famously claimed
players could plant an acorn and watch it
grow into a tree over the course of the game,
a feature that had to be cut in the final
version.
The game Yonder: The Cloud Catcher Chronicles
was not produced by Molyenux.
Yet as writer Matt Paprocki points out in
his review of the title… in that game, you
actually can watch acorns grow into trees.
Which is impressive, because Yonder is a small
indie project — but one with a strong sense
of the kind of world it wants to build.
The map is tiny, the creature variety limited
— yet Yonder’s ecosystem feels more fully
realized than many big-budget titles.
I think it’s an intriguing contrast to Dau-style
megaprojects, suggesting that not all worlds
need a thousand layers of detail to feel alive.
Do Red Dead’s intricacies make the game
better?
I mean, don’t get me wrong, they certainly
do part of the time — these might be the
most stunning environments I’ve ever had
the pleasure of exploring.
But on the other hand, sometimes the excess
feels like… well, excess.
I think one detail in particular sums up this
dichotomy the best, and it’s probably one
you’ve never noticed.
The stars in Red Dead shine ever so slightly
more brightly in the wilderness than they
do in urban areas.
Which is accurate, but also…
what a detail to include!
On the one hand it seems crazy to bother with
adding such a subtle real-world imperfection.
But on the other hand, I think it’s kind
of perfect.
Because Red Dead Redemption II isn’t just
a game about exploring a breathtaking world;
it’s also about the end of one.
Rapid industrialization changed the very landscape
of the United States.
Expanding cities and railways replaced forests
and fields, destroying and displacing indigenous
communities.
All these themes are present in the game’s
lengthy story, but they’re also present
in the land itself.
Even when you’re not in a city, there’s
a transient quality to the game’s ecosystems,
a sense that none of this will remain as it
is.
Not even the stars.
I felt this dimming of a natural era most
strongly when inhabiting the perspective of
animals.
Which is again, really weird, because none
of that is meant to be in the game.
But trying to steer a buffalo through an urban
area is so visually and mechanically powerful
— it instills a feeling in your animal bones
that this is a world that no longer belongs
to you.
Maybe it’s silly to read this much into
a fan-made add-on, but I think it’s a testament
to how thorough this world is that it can
serve as a canvas for experiences the developers
never intended.
Having said all this, I do think there needs
to be some reckoning with the fact that these
ecosystems don’t always work perfectly.
I’ve recorded a lot of game footage for
this channel, and one thing I always edit
out are glitches — moments where creatures
freak out or just behave in an unusual manner.
Even the most impressive virtual biospheres
have these sorts of hiccups.
When it comes to immersion, glitches are almost
universally regarded as a negative.
But in a strange way, I think they can sometimes
make a world feel more realistic.
Nature doesn’t always act rationally, just
look at the Comedy Wildlife Photography Awards
— a contest where the top nature photographers
share photos of animals, essentially, glitching
out.
Animals aren’t always perfect at being animals
in real life, so it’s kind of fitting that
the same is true in the virtual realm.
For example, I had a lot of trouble recording
footage of bears in Red Dead for this video,
because some problem with their code meant
they just would not do what I wanted.
But I think that’s kind of appropriate — bears
don’t like doing what people tell them to,
they’re bears!
I’m not sure any ecosystem embodies the
playful side of nature better than the one
in Alba: A Wildlife Adventure.
The final title I want to discuss today, Alba
is something of the spiritual and mechanical
opposite of a game like Red Dead.
Its world is bright and stylized instead of
grim and realistic.
Instead of playing as an outlaw you play as
a kid trying to document all the animals on
an island.
And the map itself is really tiny — a carefully
curated slice of life.
You even have a little book full of all the
wildlife you can find, it’s… really charming.
Which is why it’s a surprise to learn that
this world, too, is coming to an end.
You find out early in the game that all these
environments will be replaced to make room
for a hotel development.
And as you might imagine, this world’s fate
isn’t as unalterable as the fate of the
United States in Red Dead.
I mean, it’s a kids’ game.
But it’s telling that the creators felt
the need to include this element.
I don’t really think you can craft an ecosystem-centric
story without themes of ecological destruction
seeping in.
Even Lost Ember, which takes place in a fantasy
realm radically divergent from our own, subtly
explores the tension between nature and humanity
through its story of a fallen civilization.
These are ideas you can’t really escape,
even if they’re something only felt in the
background.
But in games with living ecosystems, the backgrounds
become the foregrounds.
I know this is an aspect of Red Dead that
frustrated some people.
I mean — the game is advertised as this
action-centric cowboy adventure — and it
is that, for some of the time.
But at least 60 percent of this game is just
riding your horse through natural vistas.
On my first play through, that seemed like
a weird allocation of time, but now, I’m
not so sure.
In environment-focused games, it is the backdrop,
the minutia, and all those little, pointless
details… that become the whole point.
My experiences with these worlds have stayed
with me, they’re something I carry around
in the jumble of my thoughts.
Long after I’ve pressed the power button
and turned off these ecosystems for good,
they’ve continued to have a life of their
own.
These worlds linger.
They’re alive.
And as always, thanks for watching.
If you enjoyed this entry, please lend your
support by liking, subscribing, and hitting
the notification icon to stay up to date on
all things Curious.
See you in the next video.